[Applause]  all right people hate it i'm saying  let me just say this people hated  the the um the queen movie  okay bohemian rhapsody yes they hated it  everyone hated it i actually liked it  i liked it and dude killed it the actor  who killed it they got  a night at the museum i don't know his  name yeah um  that was a good movie the elton john  movie not so much  yo shout out to el and john actually  he's he's a legend  you know that's one of my biggest  inspirations when i shoot videos i try  to look like him  okay what'd you think of that movie it  was good it was uh  i just think they should have gave a  heads up saying it was a musical  true we get no heads up you just like  saw the trailer and you like diving  yeah what the [ __ ] then you go in there  and they go it's like oh  [ __ ] it's a musical but i love ellen  john and i um  i love him very much and if he didn't  exist i don't think i'd be here honestly  because he's influenced me so much